From embodying country music icon Johnny Cash
in Walk the Line down to his distinctive singing
voice, to the vicious sadism of the Emperor
in Gladiator, Joaquin Phoenix has proven that
his range is virtually unmatched but his rise
to fame was neither assured or straightforward.
Born Joaquin Rafael Bottom on October 28,
1974 in Puerto Rico, Phoenix had nomadic early
years as his parents were members of the Children
of God Christian missionary group, now classified
as a cult.
Because of their involvement in that organization,
the Bottoms traveled all over south and central
America, until the cult's increasingly sinister
practices including alleged sexual abuse and
incest began to disenchant Joaquin's parents.
After escaping Children of God, and returning
to the US with their five kids in tow, the
Bottoms eventually settled in Los Angeles.
They changed their last name from Bottom to
Phoenix, and Joaquin also decided to go by
the first name Leaf so he could match better
with his brother River, and their sisters
Summer, Rain, and Liberty.
The Phoenix kids played music on the streets
for rent money until their mom, Arlyn (aka
Heart), got a job as a secretary to an NBC
casting agent.
Through her networking, a well-known casting
agent was won over by the family's talent
and shepherded them into the bright lights
of Hollywood.
Joaquin Phoenix went by his chosen name Leaf
for the first few years of his acting career,
but it was actually his brother who snagged
the first screen role in the television show
Seven Brides for Seven Brothers.
River quickly brought his family along - Joaquin
had his first TV role on that show too, immediately
followed by a string of small roles on TV.
As River's star began to rise in movies with
his breakout in Stand By Me, Joaquin also
landed juicy lead roles in SpaceCamp in 1986
and Russkies in 1987.
"Stay put for the next hour or so and nobody
gets hurt."
Joaquin's first truly big break wouldn't come
until 1989 with the Steve Martin family dramedy
Parenthood as troubled youngster Garry, a
boy struggling with his father's abandonment
of his family.
The film was a hit, and Phoenix was nominated
for a Young Artist Award for Best Leading
Young Actor for this nuanced and heartbreaking
performance.
"He didn't think it was such a good idea.
I gotta go."
But just as Joaquin was set to follow in his
brother's successful footsteps, another tragedy
hit his family that prevented him from acting
for almost two years.
On Halloween night in 1993, Joaquin Phoenix
was at Hollywood nightclub the Viper Room
when his brother River overdosed on a cocktail
of drugs.
Joaquin was the one who called 911 while their
sister Rain tried to resuscitate River using
CPR.
River died later at the hospital, a trauma
that impacted Joaquin and the Phoenix family
immeasurably.
Joaquin was only 19; his brother had recently
turned 23.
Joaquin Phoenix was so devastated by his brother's
sudden death that he didn't act for almost
two years.
By this time, Joaquin's parents had split
up and his father John had moved back to South
America.
While Joaquin's mom and sisters retreated
to their family property in Florida and the
safety of their connection in privacy to mourn
and heal, Joaquin went to live and travel
with his father instead.
Joaquin Phoenix was hit extremely hard losing
his brother River, but when he came back to
acting, he did so with a vengeance.
He decided to return to his given name Joaquin
instead of Leaf, seen for the first time in
the credits of Gus Van Sant's critically acclaimed
film To Die For which kickstarted a fierce
new chapter of Phoenix's career in 1995.
"Now, I take it very serious."
After the success of To Die For, Phoenix went
on to work with Oliver Stone on U-Turn, then
went on to the romantic drama Inventing the
Abbotts and the thrillers Clay Pigeons and
8MM.
But it wasn't until Ridley Scott's Gladiator
that Phoenix's talents brought him his first
Oscar nomination for his layered performance
as Emperor Commodus.
By the time he worked with M. Night Shyamalan
on Signs and The Village, Phoenix had become
a full-fledged movie star.
While Joaquin Phoenix's earlier roles were
each marked with singular iterations of Phoenix's
profound emotional depth, he took things to
a new level with his method acting in Walk
the Line in 2005, embodying Johnny Cash down
to his singing voice and earning a Grammy
as well as a Golden Globe for his tremendous
work.
Diving deep emotionally and physically to
embody Johnny Cash and the addictions that
shaped his life and career would also come
with a dark side for Joaquin Phoenix: After
filming for Walk the Line wrapped, he checked
himself into rehab for a brief stint.
Phoenix had never been more than a social
drinker before Walk the Line, and had increased
his alcohol consumption significantly to better
understand Cash.
As he told London Magazine,
"I was really leaning on alcohol to feel okay.
That's really what it was."
During this difficult time, Phoenix also had
a terrifying brush with death when his brakes
failed and his car crashed.
Amazingly, he was rescued by documentary filmmaker
Verner Herzog, and nobody was badly injured.
From 2009 to 2010 the public at large was
worried about Joaquin Phoenix, wondering if
he was on drugs or worse when he announced
his retirement from acting to become a rapper.
This period was marked with Phoenix behaving
erratically in interviews and talk shows like
his now-infamous David Letterman appearance
all of which would turn out to be an elaborate
piece of performance art directed by Phoenix's
then-brother-in-law Casey Affleck that was
eventually turned into the mockumentary I'm
Still Here.
"These guys have seen the worst of me, they've
seen the best, they've seen the honest me."
After this odd detour, Phoenix went on to
stun audiences and critics with his role as
Freddie Quell in Paul Thomas Anderson's The
Master, which earned him his third Oscar nomination.
He also starred in Spike Jonze's strangely
poignant tech-oriented dramedy Her, as a lonely
man who falls in love with his computer operating
system, to name just one standout role he's
had in his post-performance art years.
Riding a wave of critical acclaim for his
performance in the comics-inspired 2019 drama
Joker, Joaquin Phoenix received the Toronto
International Film Festival Tribute Actor
Award alongside Meryl Streep.
The award recognizes decades of cinematic
excellence, and during his acceptance speech
Joaquin made rare and emotional comments about
his late brother River, saying,
"When I was 15 or 16, my brother River came
home from work and he had a VHS copy of a
movie called Raging Bull, and he sat me down
and made me watch it.
And the next day he woke me up, and he made
me watch it again.
And he said, 'You're going to start acting
again, this is what you're going to do.
[...] He didn't ask me, he told me.
And I am indebted to him for that because
acting has given me such an incredible life."
Phoenix also credited his father John for
gifting him with an exceptional work ethic
that helped him get to this point, but also
quipped that it might not have fully been
on display on the Joker set.
“Haha.”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.